what real criminal case inspired the
character of Eddie Munson and what does
11 have in common with Luke Skywalker
keep watching for Easter eggs you might
have missed in season 4 Volume 2 of
stranger things but beware there are
spoilers ahead
when speaking with Netflix's tadam The
Duffer Brothers hinted at the fact that
Eddie Munson is inspired by a specific
person who is a Dungeons and Dragons
fanatic and Metal Head just like Eddie a
tweet from Netflix geeked confirmed that
Eddie Munson is Loosely based on West
Memphis three-member Damien Eckles a
writer and artist these days Eccles was
one of three teenagers convicted under
highly dubious circumstances of the 1993
murders of Steve Branch Michael Moore
and Christopher Byers and what the media
considered at the time to be Satanic
rituals Eccles had a tendency for
dressing in black and listening to heavy
metal which led the community to
ostracize him and believe he conducted
spiritual practices with ties to
Witchcraft and Satanism in an interview
about season 4 Ross stuffer said
something we really wanted to get into
this year was the satanic Panic the term
satanic Panic refers to a period in the
80s and 90s when Society began blaming
its various ills on the influence of
heavy metal music and Fantastical
imagery from Escapist entertainment like
Dungeons and Dragons
Advocates of the satanic Panic were
specifically concerned about supposed
satanists harming and sacrificing small
children there's a widely held opinion
that what happened at the daycare was
the devil's handiwork The West Memphis
Three were released from prison in 2011.
Echols went on to become a New York
Times best-selling author and produced a
documentary about his experience when
describing the character of Eddie Matt
Duffer said what's sad about his
narrative is that the people who get to
know him love him and the people who
don't have judged him horribly
it's no secret that the creators of
stranger things love to pay respect to
horror classics with the numerous
references they sprinkle throughout the
series and season 4 is no different at
one point Joyce and Hopper come across a
Russian Lab of tanks filled with demic
organs for experimentation and the scene
is almost identical to one in Alien
Resurrection a 1997 movie that just like
stranger things co-stars Winona Ryder
however The Duffer Brothers didn't stop
there there are several other nods to
the alien film franchise throughout the
season such as Paul reiser's use of the
word kiddo Burke reiser's character in
Aliens also makes frequent use of the
patronizing nickname references to the
Stephen King horror classic carry appear
throughout the season as well like when
Elle gets bullied in front of her whole
school and when Max's happy memory of
the winter ball is ruined by
blood-filled balloons the dupper
brothers have confirmed that when
planning the season they focused a lot
on a Nightmare on Elm Street Hellraiser
and the IT miniseries it also said they
modeled after Pinhead from Hellraiser
and of course Robert England plays
Henry's Father Victor creel which means
vechna's dad is pretty much Freddy
Krueger
those final two episodes Volume 2 are
extremely action-packed but did you
notice a familiar weapon amid all the
chaos as revealed by David Harbor on his
personal Instagram page the sword used
by Hopper to slay the demic organ in the
final episode is actually the same
Atlantean sword famously used by Arnold
Schwarzenegger and the Conan the
Barbarian films Barber describes the
prop as both quote heavy as hell and a
tremendous honor to wield fans also
pointed out some foreshadowing to this
epic sword battle that came in the first
episode of season four when we get a
glimpse of Mike's bedroom a poster for
Conan the Barbarian can be seen hanging
on his wall this tiny Easter egg
probably wouldn't have meant anything to
you prior to the finale episode with
hopper Schwarzenegger himself actually
admitted to still owning the legendary
sword and keeping it in his office when
asked if he still had the sword back in
2010 the actor and one-time governor of
California confirmed that he in fact did
and he plays a vital role in the final
moments of the fight with bekna by
sacrificing himself for the greater good
and what is definitely the most metal
concert in the history of the upside
down Eddie shreds to Metallica in order
to distract the demo bats the song Eddie
performs Master of Puppets is of clear
significance given the way vecna tends
to toy with his victims by forcing them
to relive their worst fears and traumas
mechna is basically a metaphorical
Master of Puppets Metallica actually
reposted the clip on their Instagram
page crazy in the show for how well they
Incorporated the song admit to being
blown away by the final product writing
some folks were able to guess the song
just by seeing a few seconds of Joseph
Quinn's hands in the trailer Eddie's
fate sadly seemed to be written in stone
from his first appearance if you look
closely at Eddie's arms you'll see a
tattoo of bats as well as another tattoo
of hand controlling a puppet on strings
direct connections to the circumstances
of his inevitable death
I didn't run away this time right The
Duffer Brothers sat down with collider
and revealed that they had taken a lot
of inspiration from the Star Wars
franchise Matt Duffer said we have
always wanted to do an Empire Strikes
Back ending we tried to do that with
season four where it's the sense of loss
Star Wars episode 5 The Empire Strikes
Back is known for its shocking ending
where the bad guys more or less Prevail
sadly vechna likewise kinda prevails
when the upside down leaks into the real
world of Hawkins Indiana there's also a
similarity between 11 and Luke Skywalker
both characters abandon extensive
training sessions against their mentors
wishes in order to help their friends in
Luke's case his decision leads to the
loss of his hand and Han Solo being
taken prisoner and elevens her attempt
to intervene in beckton's plans leads to
Max's coma blinding and possible
paralysis but one must not Overlook the
moment when Murray utters one of the
most famous lines from the entire Star
Wars franchise I got a bad feeling about
this
there's no denying that Tom Cruise was
an 80s heartthrob following his roles in
Risky Business and Top Gun it's safe to
say that Crews had a dedicated fan base
back in the day and Nancy wheeler was
most definitely a member not only does
Nancy have a Tom Cruise poster stuck on
her wall as of the very first season and
mentions him on several occasions she
and Steve actually dress up as risky
business characters for Halloween back
in season 2. Robin briefly teases Nancy
about her poster which still hangs on
her wall in season four you have a Tom
Cruise poster that's oh
a Reddit user also pointed out the
visual similarities between Steve from
stranger things and Steve from The
Outsiders played by Cruz clearly Nancy
has a type and we can't blame her when
the gang gets together to plan their
attack on vechna they decide to stock up
on weapons at a store called The War
Zone when Eddie points out an
advertisement for the place we see the
company's logo takes clear inspiration
from the Top Gun logo Mason die who
portrays the unhinged jock Jason did an
interview with the Steve barley show and
explained that Tom Cruise was the main
inspiration behind his character he said
I sat down with the dubber brothers and
producer Sean Levy and they were like
okay Jason is just Tom Cruise from his
80s movies so I just went back and
watched Risky Business Top Gun like all
his 80 movies a week prior to filming
in the final episodes of the Season
viewers learned that there was a large
significance surrounding the number four
not only does it clock chime four times
whenever vechna is about to claim
another victim but he also requires
exactly four victims to enact his plan
in order for the upside down to break
through to the regular Dimension Beckman
needs to create four portals which
ultimately results in the four cracks
seen in the final scenes of the Season
while all of this is explicitly
explained throughout the series there
are some additional references that
aren't as noticeable the main characters
are all split into four distinct groups
the Hellfire gang in Hawkins L and papa
in the training facility Hopper and
Joyce in Russia and will encompanying
California it makes this the first
season where characters fight the main
antagonist simultaneously from different
locations across the globe and other
sides of the dimensional barrier if you
were so inclined you could theorize that
the importance of the number four could
relate to the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse though we can only hope more
explanations unfold next season
one of the best parts about stranger
things is dissecting the countless
Easter eggs and background details
scattered throughout for example while
the Hawkins group scrambles to find
music to bring Nancy back from Becca's
mindscape we catch a glimpse of Eddie's
bedroom if you look closely his walls
are packed with posters from various
heavy metal bands ranging from Iron
Maiden Anthrax Judas priests Slayer and
Creator proving he is a true Metalhead
an example of subtle symbolism occurs
during the moments of Brenner's death in
the desert as a camera pans over him he
can be seen in a crucifix pose most
likely mirroring the christ-like way in
which he viewed himself however the
camera then flips the image upside down
in order to evoke the evil that Brenner
truly created by bringing becna into
this world when the Hawkins kids go to
the war zone to stock up on weapons they
quickly pass by a bulletin board covered
with wanted posters for all the members
of hellfire club showing that most of
the Town had succumbed to satanic Panic
by this point during the same visit
Robin catches a glimpse of her school
Crush Vicki who is sadly getting cozy
with some guy meanwhile there are
uncanny similarities between Vicky's
wardrobe and the look of Molly
ringwald's character in 16 Candles which
would have been released about three
years earlier which could imply that
Vicky is a John Hughes fan check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
foreign